night craw is one of your best
performances don't you think thanks U
well it's one of the best scripts I've
ever and you got skinny waisted for that
why for that character because the the
character when I read it on the page I
felt like if I was like in the shape I'm
normally in I try and like be I'm pretty
athletic and I like to be in shape and
like if I felt like if I it didn't feel
right for the character to me it didn't
feel like he was somebody who didn't eat
a lot of food cuz he he he he he
couldn't really afford to really pay for
anything and he was always in his brain
verbal talking all the time so he
wouldn't be an athletic looking guy yeah
and I just I felt like there was
something about him that I wanted to
make clear which and I needed to do that
physically how do you lose 35 lbs in
that uh rapid amount of time what do you
do do you just starve yourself it wasn't
too rapid I mean I took some time took a
few months but I I yeah I mean you eat
lot a lot less and I ran I ran and ran I
would just start running I ran like 15
miles a day at a certain
point